the ruble slid on this news it slid in
valley but if you look at the chart it
actually moves up I'll show you that in
a minute but this was a real surprise to
economists only one economist that we
surveyed had anticipated a rate cut
because the central bank had raised
rates six times in the last year now the
government is basically signaling that
it's willing to let the ruble appreciate
depreciate in value excuse me it's
willing to sacrifice some of the rubles
value and prospect of higher inflation
in order to stabilize the economy and
pull it out of recession so let's take
you inside the Bloomberg terminal to
show you the dollar ruble exchange rate
this is the dollar strengthening versus
of ruble so the dollars moving up in
value the ruble is weakening in value
this is over the last six months and as
the line goes higher the dollar is
increasing in value this is today's move
with the ruble going beyond 70 at 70.7
one this was back in mid December when
the government unexpectedly raised
interest rates by a huge amount and that
pushed ruble past 80 that was pretty
short lived at the time because there
were talk of government intervention
perhaps the central bank came in to
stabilize things and we did see the
ruble exchange rate find some kind of
equilibrium in the weeks following but
this move higher certainly indicates
that the government is willing once
again to let the ruble devalue now in
terms of the effect on equities this was
a move by the central bank to support
the real economy so you are seeing a bit
of a reaction a positive reaction in
russian stocks the mice xfer index for
instances of eight tenths of one percent
in afternoon trading